I'm really happy to be here it's my
first time at pycon
and I was already told that it's well
big conference in the sense that we've
um we have just listened they're 1 700
attendees
but I was told that it's still familiar
so I'm quite excited what's expecting me
the next three days
and but I definitely know what is
expecting you in the next 40 minutes
so the title of this talk
doesn't leave space for speculations wow
they're just coming in and in
cool
wow
it's getting full
no never start on time
[Laughter]
wow
it's getting really full
yeah
wow so welcome again to everybody who
joined us
um I'm happy that this year of the
today's talk
fascinates you
because you've chosen the way to this
room
and well the title of the talk is from
notebook to pipeline in no time with
linear pipe so
I present you a way to convert a
notebook to a pipeline like Apache
airflow array
Argo DVC but I'll not do it by hands not
by fair means no I'll use a very new
cool and open source cool linear Pi
because it saves you time and nerves
um for me this is a relevant job because
I have to do it a lot of times
at least you're sitting here so it seems
to be also relevant for you but in case
you are not convinced why you should
convert a notebook into a pipeline let's
just wrote a big picture
so let us assume we're all data
scientists or well at least we get a
project where we do something with data
and AI
and
such a project normally starts with
doing analyzers on the data
doing some prototyping
we are looking for modal for example
machine learning model which works which
does the trick and we got the goal that
in the end
we provide a service a micro server so
we have to integrate it in a product
and from going from the left to the
right you cross a line
and the line separates the field of
development from the field of operations
so it separates depth from Ops or when
you do machine learning ml Ops
so what's the characteristics of these
fields
in development
you're looking for iterations
you're looking for feedback
we don't write code
well in a complete sense no we are
implementing some lines
we are writing a test we are starting
the compiler we get feedback does it
work does it not work so in the
development side
we just try to get things working
and on the mlop side or upside
the focus switches so we want to keep
things working we don't want that
something changes without Our intention
and the last three years tools have
emerged for those two sites
so a classic choice
for the development size are Jupiter
notebooks
Jupiter notebooks are great for doing
experiments
we get immediate feedbacks
we can do a lot of things without doing
other things we did before because we're
just using variables in the memory
and Jupiter notebooks are great
but they are also bad because they are
not reproducible so when we've ever
tried to share a European notebook you
know what I mean
so
on the other side
there are pipelines pipelines like
Apache airflow DVC argue and kubeflow
and it makes sense to use pipelines
because pipelines are reproducible
you're fixing things there
you can check them in and you get
you track the code
and when you track it you can do
continuous machine learning because you
get Matrix out of your CI CD you can do
continuous improvements
well when there's so many benefits in
Pipelines
so let's transform our notebook into our
pipeline can't be so harder
well when you think about your last
experimentations in a Jupiter notebook
it's not because a Jupiter notebook is
normally a mess
so um it all starts for example with
package management
who does fix the version when he does a
pip install
nobody just to pip install package
so that's where it starts you're
completely dependent on what the Jupiter
notebook at the time finds in your
package management system and you rely
on the underlying jupyter kernel you
probably don't know about it
false problem in reproduction
so
and the second problem is
that you're playing with variables
so you just use variables you reuse them
you transform them you just
yeah do a lot of things you delete cells
you edit this you depend on variables
which were generated from deleted cells
so
and and that's only the first thing so
the second thing is that your order of
your cells does not reflect the order of
execution
and there's no history about what you
did in the past
so when you found a model
you rely on your brain what you did
until the model worked and perhaps you
are lost in reproducing these steps
but
that's a solution
you can use linear pipe for all this and
it does a lot of stuff for you and saves
your lives in case
okay
and to see how this works
we are
well
we look on a simple example but before
we prepare our notebook
so if you want to give superpowers to
your notebook you have to do these
freeze lines before first you do a pip
install linear pi and you don't start
fixing the version because you never did
okay then you load linear pi as
extension
and that's where the superpower begins
because now
linear Pi watches the memory for you
it looks how you arrive to the variable
what did you do on the memory
it looks about the ancestors of the
memory of the um of the variables that's
where the word comes from lineage
and last but not least
you import linear pi
because we want to use some methods from
that package
okay so far so good fasten your seat
belts
a simple example so we say variable a
equals one variable b equals two I'm
allowed to use these variables because I
studied math so I get the license to use
such variables
and in the third line we sum up those
two variables C equals a plus b
C equals 3 just to point
and the first thing linear pi
well gives us is a method called save
we save the variable C as artifact name
c
and
now comes a magic part we can now say
okay let me just print the code what
happened how did I came to this artifact
and linear Pi now connects
all the things together
and it says okay in order to reach C
you've done the definition of a the
definition of b and after this summed it
up
and this even worked
well it works
when you've deleted the cell before you
did the artifact safe
because linear Pi doesn't watch the
cells it watches the memory what happens
there inside
that's pretty cool I think so because
when you get to the point your model
worked
you can just say okay I saved the code
which
delivered me this
code those model
foreign
so let's push the limits a bit
we
now to a small import we import numpy
but just to do a simple multiplication
as complex as possible
so we Define a parameter my parameter
equals three
and then
we multiply C by the parameter using
numpy Okay the reason is that D equals
nine
so far so good
and
we do the same thing again we Define an
artifact
and print out the code so I've missed to
copy the print command there but I just
want to see uh show you the result I
hope you trust me that this is the
result in fact and linearpa also tracks
the inputs
so you also get the informations on what
imports you rely on and this will be
also important later
to build the pipeline and we are just
one step before building a pipeline so
this feature we are all waiting for
let's see
linear Pi has another method not only
the save method but also the two
pipeline method
and we are now saying linear Pi okay
take the two artifacts C and D
and
we'll build a pipeline for me
so on the framework should be in my case
DVC because I like DVC pipelines we'll
see later on why
but it could also be a Kube flow
pipeline Apache airflow pipeline Argo or
even Ray I just looked inside the code
yesterday and I saw this there's also a
ray plug-in inside
okay and to make things
a bit more complicated we say that an
input parameter of the pipeline should
be my parameter
that's perhaps important when you do
machine learning and you find a good
solution for a model but you want to do
hyper parameter optimization then you
can use the pipeline in order to just
play around with the parameters
okay
and then
we just say
there's a pipeline name my pipeline
output directory cool and let's see
what's happening
now linear byte does linear Pi does a
lot of work for us so it generates
multiple files so first of all a module
file
and we'll
dive into these files later on the
module file contains the source code
which we also extracted before using the
print command and the getcode method
and we get a requirements file
we'll see that what's inside there but
lineup I tracks in fact all the packages
which were used in the kernel
and
then I get four DHE files related to the
DVC pipeline and last but not least a
photographer I like Docker files
and we'll see later on why
okay but um
let's just go into the source code file
so this is an extraction of the my
pipeline module file
and first of all we see
that it also Imports numpy there
because it's now aggregating all the
artifact code
and
he's
generating code how you get to the
artifact C this reflects
the output we saw before for artifact
and now
the next code get the slightly different
from the thing we saw before
because linear buy just analyzed the two
artifacts
and realized oh D relies on C
so we don't have to do here the
recomputation of C now to see by fair
means from the beginning no we'll use C
to return
and
the user said my parameter is an input
parameter so before the my part my
parameter variable was defined as my
parameter equals three
but now it's an input parameter of the
method
and we see later under the DHE files why
and last but not least it returns as d
so
it's not only the code we got before
when we printed it with the get code
method linear Pi just
put the things together
in order to build a multi-stage pipeline
as DVC supports
who's in common with UBC Pipelines
one person oh it's a pity you should use
it
[Laughter]
use DVC pipelines now one thing I like
at DVC pipelines is
the DVC keeps track on things you've
already computated
so
and to get this trick you have to Define
in this yaml how things are connected
so
linear Pi generated a multi-stage DVC
pipeline for us because linear Pi
realized that D relies on C
so and here in this yaml DBC yaml we
also have these multi-stages and the
first stage is to compute the variable C
and doing so
he calls a command so every DVC yummer
provides in every stage a command which
has to be executed and you tell DVC okay
this the stage relies on source code of
course so for here for example the my
pipeline module where all the code is
inside
and well it relies on
of course the source code file you're
executing
and on the other hand
you say oh okay when you execute this
there's an output and
in our case
linear Pi um
saves the artifacts between the stages
and pickle files so we come back to this
later why this can be a problem but it's
it's a common choice
and the next stage
on the stage D you also have a little
helper file tasky
we also refer on the dependencies on the
source code file pipeline module and
task d
and now
we say also that it depends on this
pickle file which is the output of the
first stage
so what does DVC doing now for you TVC
is tracking the
check sums of the files
and
want to check some of these two files
didn't change
DVC says okay then this output will also
not change
and if the output didn't change well the
stage D depends on
then I don't have to do the computation
either
only when these two files are changed
just think about machine learning you
get several stages so Forbes loading the
data pre-processing the data
training the the model
and doing some evaluation
when you change the evaluation you don't
want the first three stages
be changed or recomputed
you're saving a lot of energy because
gpus are using energy every computation
needs energy
so your carbon footprint is reduced by
using DVC just remember it
I think it's important to say because we
have to take care about our Earth
so
um that's why I like DVC Pipelines
and just to come back what linear Pi is
doing for us
it also will add apparent section in the
stage deep whereas they will because
I've seen that I left a box so I did
this contribution which generates this
code and I have to fix this
but I'll do it when I derive from Berlin
to Munich in the train
it's not a big deal
um
it's also perhaps a good point to um to
mention how are these files generated so
linear Pi uses Ginger templates
and you're passing Warrior to the ginger
templates and
um this Ginger pantries are generating
these files
in a deterministic way okay
so this was the DBC Yama and
um let's dive into into well into the
other DHE files
so this is the first helper file the
task c
um python file we see we import pickle
chest to execute the code get C in order
to get the variable C and to dump it
in a pickle object
and that's the first thing which can
break
Your solution
who tried to pickle a tensorflow model
in this room
yeah did it work yeah it didn't work
yeah that's it so um you cannot pick
every object
for tensorflow object it's not
tensorflow models it's not possible
there are other
things you cannot pickle and
there are also things you shouldn't
pickle because they're a more efficient
way to save it so if you want to store a
pandas data frame you want to use the
hdf format or something like this so
this pickle attempt is a first shot but
it has to improved in future
but it's open source you're um if you
have good ideas so also linear Pi
Community is discussing about this how
this can be done
um will there be an attribute in the
notebook telling them oh don't use the
pickle use something else so um that's
something we're thinking about
how to change it in future and how to
reflect these edge cases which are not
educated I think so it's really
important to fix this
okay
but
we got an artifact and the artifact
is loaded again in The Next Step so this
helper file this these task C task D
help of us are doing the job for you
installing objects and loading them back
again
and last but not least we see that
linear Pi also now takes care about the
input parameter
so it passes the input parameter to the
method
and the parameters in fact stored
in the parents Yama and
you can say DVC okay here's my power on
Signal when the parameter gets changed
it's connected to the stage and you have
to recompute the stage
and that's how things
are glued together
okay
any questions so far in the room yeah
yeah
it was when it made in one task
oh
um
yeah okay I'll read this because okay so
um your name is
oh really a real ask why did we
separated
um the computation in different stages
that's that's a good point yeah that's a
good point so in fact you can
there's another argument in the two
pipeline method you can say Okay I want
everything in one stage so
um for other Frameworks also so they are
possible to to say Okay I want not
everything in one set but multiple stage
so it depends on the plugin so there's a
DVC plugin framework plug-in there is an
airflow framework plugging Ray Cube flow
Etc they all have different arguments on
what
choose as a solution so it's it's
completely well and this was also the
first thing implemented by the linear Pi
team to just put all together in a
single stage it's a fair choice because
um when you say um
when something changes
you have to do most properly everything
it's completely fine so it was my choice
to do this multi-stage attempt and
that's why I contributed to this
multi-stage
attempt to the library
so it's both possible
yeah
oh
can you separate
on scripts from the data so for example
that the data output is done to a
subdirectory data and
yeah
um your name is Mark Marx
um just said two questions the first was
related to tie pins so I think it should
be possible it will make the ginger
table 8 more complex but it should be
possible I think
it's a bit work
the second thing is could you also
choose a directory not single objects
um
would also be
some sort of
work so I don't know whether it's
straightforward to implement but that's
also a big plus point of the linear Pi
team so they're really Community Driven
so when I just said oh
it's a real pity that you don't have DVC
pipelines and multi-stage DVC pipelines
and they said oh okay we don't have so
much
practice in doing DVC do you want to do
the contribution and I said why not and
they really helped me a lot so
um for Andrew helped me a lot to
implement the code and I think
just trying to select community of
linear pi
they're really
um
nice developers and they're happy for
feedback and
perhaps you're also doing your next
contribution to linear Pi yeah
randomly transforming it you know
this was blogging your capacity of data
Maybe in a random way with some a seal
or something like that but anyways it's
kind of not always fixed but they sense
of data you know
you know
um so you mean you leave the notebook
using somehow an individual individual
implementations or individual tools
outside are you calling a command bash
command or something like this
loading
of these database forming them with some
randomness
[Music]
okay so see but then
um
yeah
oh oh okay okay so uh I'm not use that
because I hear you
um so just to repeat the question so
when you're doing computer version
you're loading the model and you're
doing some random stuff on it or random
stuff on the data you um how is this
Randomness reflected in in such a
pipeline so
um
I think
when you really want to do a pipeline
out of it you have to fix the randomness
but on the level of what Randomness
you're doing so for example when I do a
splitting
um a pandas with Escalon and test data
splitting I set a seat I think you have
to set the seed in the code because
arbitrary Randomness cannot be reflected
by transforming it into a pipeline
does this yeah
huh
we have to see I think let's make a pair
programming session afterwards
we also have some slides left okay but
yeah
oh overhead do you mean when executing
the cells
a good point I didn't look for it but I
think it's really ah it's the session
chair really does a good job so I have
to repeat the question so is there is
there an overhead computation overhead
in doing so so do I slow down my
computations
um I don't know but I don't think much
but I have to admit I don't know
but trying to select Community ask a
question because the Doris and the other
developers they have really good
insights there
okay
um I see we are really having good
questions but um I got some slides rests
and um I'll just go forward to these
slides so
um we are now through that the achieve
us so we also mentioned what are the
problems what the future
um ways of contributing for Solutions
and we are now coming to the docker file
and package management so when you look
inside the docker file
on the first line
it doesn't from python 3.8 which is a
very generic choice so a linear Pi chest
looked what's your python current so
what python version did you choose okay
and then it says okay then I'll load the
python image then it's copies the
requirements file to
to
the building process in the dockercon
the image and
it doesn't pip install and when we look
inside the requirements file
lineupai does not only say oh install
numpy no it also looks inside the kernel
what version is there
and that's cool I think because you
don't have to do this
and
they're now
two things I think to say about the
choice of photographer
I already said that I like Docker files
because I only trust python interpreters
in Docker file because they are really
robust in the sense of reproducible
and
that's the pro but there's a small
drawback in the Stocker file so if you
want to do machine learning you want to
use gpus
and when you do the generic Choice from
python frequency you don't have GPU
support
even if you insert your Pi torch coder
libraries or something like this
but that's fine for me because I did a
lot
of image building
to get Cuda support on my hardware and
it's not easy
so at some point you'll still fail so
for example when you um when there was
the switch from Cuda version 10 to Cuda
version 11 you had to install libraries
from the 10th version and the 11th
version just to get it running and
I think GPU is at the moment still too
Pacific as specific as to
um as to automate the thing so
um if you would like to automate it you
have to say oh linear Pi I got this
Hardware in a100 Oh no I got an AMD
Hardware please um look for proper
images
in combination with the packages I'm
using and ah no I don't think that this
so if you're using gpus you know what's
waiting for you and I think um it's the
best to fix it yourself
um yeah
so
from my point of view this choice is
really completely fine
and then there are some
um yeah lines of code doing this DBC
thing
whoever tried to dockerize a DVC so we
only got one person here inside that
your Docker rise your DVC pipeline then
you know these lines you need to do this
you need to get in it you need a DVC in
it so this is boilerplate code and I'm
happy that I don't have to write
boilerplate code
that's it
okay
so far so good
no
I think linear pi
really saves you times and nerves
to get from a notebook to a pipeline
because it does a lot of things in
refactoring
saving your lives
when you edited or deleted cells
which you need it for your solution
and I have to say I will never review a
notebook again
a notebook is a well
it's a story for itself so there are
some solutions but I'm not happy with
them and I've just discussed this with
my team so
I think before I review a notebook I can
I would transform it with a linear Pi
into a pipeline because then I see the
relevant code which reached um which
made the model and I can really um
just read the code which is important
and not around and
I think this will save time for me
definitely and
the question is
whether you should now use notebooks in
your CI CD because
when you get a tool which automates
the step from a notebook to a pipeline
why not just
um
check the notebook in and let the
pipeline produce in the cicd so
this sounds nice
and can be the future
but not yet we need more contributions
for this
so um
at the moment linear Pi saves you time
to get from there to there but you have
to check it by hand afterwards because
the pickle thing
it will always break something I think
yeah but
um
it really helps you to cross the line
from the F2 Ops
and
it's not the only feature so they're
working on more features they're even
working on a platform to use linear buy
and
um
just follow them on LinkedIn China on
select so there are a lot of things
which will happen in the next few months
which I think it's worth to follow
and yeah you can also think about
contributing because they're really
Community focused they're really nice to
work with so it was a pleasure for me to
work with Andrew on the code and I
really learned a lot
and
um well that's where I think we end now
also
um
I have also to say thank you to the
vogra which um the company I'm working
with they enable me to do contributions
during my working time doing open
sourcing and this is really also
something very important I think a lot
of companies use open source but they
don't
allow the workers to contribute in the
working time which I think it's a Pity
because it's not only a giving
because you also get something back you
get experience back I um I just saw
a different way to work also because
everybody has a different style of
working using other packages which you
are not aware of so it was really cool
to do this and
um yeah last but not least I want to
thank you to the organization team
because there are a lot of volunteers
who are doing a great job and also the
stuff here on the back side
camera and the audio
yeah so thank you all I hope I
helped you I hope this helps you in your
work that you're saving a lot and time
and nerves
using linear pi
[Applause]
thank you so much for your amazing talk
you just shared us a lot of knowledge
and new libraries everyone like open
source so I believe a lot of people now
are up to try and linear pie and maybe
making some pull requests to help
develop the product so that's cool and I
just want to say that we still have time
for questions you have five minutes
which is great you're perfect in timing
and guys and then you can also write
some questions to slider we are
monitoring and we'll be asking it here
to Thomas so we have questions
okay so one of the things about
notebooks is that sometimes you execute
a line and then you execute other lines
and then re-execute that line before and
that might affect the variable in
different ways how does the tracking of
that work with linear pi
yeah so linear Pi really watches you
it's like a big brother so when you did
a cell execution
it doesn't say oh you executed the cell
but you executed the code inside the
cell it remembers it even when you
deleted it edited it or manipulated it
it tracks what you're doing and not what
the cell is like
so this is the thing where linear Pi
really helps you
yes thanks I have two questions actually
first one is how does it track this
these lines how does it save them and
what kind of objects
and the second is do you have I assume
it only
reads the code in the notebook and it
doesn't go a layer deeper right so is it
possible if I import my own functions
from a pi file for example to see those
lines also
represented
okay so I'm not quite sure but I'll
start with the second question because
first one I just had problems to hear
with so um when it's outside the
notebook a library lying outside the
book which is not imported by a package
management system
at the moment it's working not but I'm
not quite sure so if you're trying to
select Community ask the question I
cannot answer it's the first one I just
had problems because so many persons
were leaving the room um can you repeat
it
yeah these um these code lines that it
tracks and shows you if you request them
again in your artifact how does it save
them simply how does it is it in
external files or how are they tracked
and saved
I don't know
sorry no um I've not looked inside the
um the really the core of linear Pi but
it's also a good news because if you
want to contribute and Implement your
own framework you don't need to know
something about how the core of linear
Pi is working on but also here join the
slack community and ask that question I
even think there is a podcast where
Doris and Andrew explained how does this
work and the intrinsics work so it's
really um join them ask them and Rule
post I think to get an answer there
I was just wondering uh how you are
using linear Pi so what is your single
source of Truth
you told us that you are usually only
looking at the generated code because
it's easier to understand than the
notebook itself
in future but the question is uh if you
have this generated code and it's easier
to understand uh will you ever go back
to the notebook where do you want to
develop further
so
I got nerfed by notebooks two years ago
and I tried not to use them but
I came back because when you're not
using notebooks as fuzzy as they are
you're missing something you're missing
Solutions and so the notebook
it fulfills so many criterias of the
first field of development iterations
getting feedback Etc that's really worth
using it
but
I'm lazy I don't want to do the
boilerplate things and refactoring my
notebook this I want to automate and
this is my ux case because I got a lot
of small AI project where I only have
two weeks time to show results and this
saves me a day or two days of work
that's it in two days of work is fine
you can go to the mountains
thank you uh just one
adding to this question actually so what
happens when you have you had run a
linear pi to create the output of files
and then you do a minor change in the
notebook and rerun it is it so
intelligent so to say to uh kind of
bring it in an intelligent way that it
doesn't mess up the whole diff the first
story so to say thank you
I think that's really the point which I
mentioned um so
will linear Pi allow you to check in the
notebook and generate the cact pipeline
automatically
so
the thing is
when
do I switch from a notebook to apply
Prime then I'm pretty sure that
the solution I found won't change much
and afterwards normally I'm working on
the hyper parameters or doing slightly
changes in the code in the pipeline code
so this is the way I would use it
but in case you want to work in The
Notebook back again so we are in future
what we've talked about which will be
perhaps problematic
um
I would do a git merge and hope that git
just does the things I did afterwards
the last time again on this newly
generated notebook so this would be my
hope at the moment to if you would to
like to stay at the notebook also for
well the next two three months of your
project
it was a pleasure to be here